an explosion at a shiite mosque in the
northern afghan city of kunduz has left
at least 50 people dead and scores more
wounded videos posted on social media
show rescuers shepherding people
including women and children away from
the scene the so-called islamic state
bid rivals of the taliban have
repeatedly targeted shiites in a bid to
stir up sectarian violence in sunni
majority afghanistan
let's go straight to afghanistan now
where journalist franz marty is standing
by friends what more can you tell us
about this latest attack
the attack happened about four hours ago
and was apparently a strong explosion
inside the mosque so around the time
of the main friday prayers
when mosques are regularly packed
there have been reports of 20 to 30
killed
and many more wounded so far no one has
claimed responsibility but it has all
the hallmarks
of uh um is attack and one of my jihadi
sources in northern afghanistan
already indicated that deutsche was
behind the attack the islamic state
but this is not yet confirmed
now this is the most fatal assault since
u.s and other western forces left the
country
do you think it's designed to
destabilize the taliban and the region
um certainly i mean it is a headline
grabbing attack
and
whoever is behind it wanted to instill
fear and grab attention and show that
the taliban can't provide security and
with the target being shy
it has
this sectarian uh undertone this
sectarian motivation
which fits the islamic state
who has been very vocal about
being against the taliban displaying
them as having sold out to the americans
by making peace and wanting to have uh
peaceful relations with the world um
so yeah it it certainly had this
propaganda motivation
now the taliban have promised to route
out these is militia cells what kind of
reaction would you expect from the
taliban to this attack
more of what they have been doing during
the past days and weeks
so not in kunduz but in kabul and in in
jalalabad and in
other parts of nangaha in eastern
afghanistan the taliban have conducted
raids uh arrested people sometimes also
killed people um
sometimes officially claiming that that
they targeted toish in
other times they haven't like officially
commented on these incidents
so there will be probably more of this
um the problem with this is that there
are credible reports from nangaha that
some of these taliban raids uh targeted
just uh salafists so while is members
are of the salafis creed not every
salafist is uh is member so apparently
there are also many innocent people
rounded up in songs in these taliban
reactions
all right all right friends mahdi thanks
very much for that franz marti in kabul
you